c'è stato un periodo su youtube in cui
tutti noi youtubers aspettavamo l'uscita
di questo gioco tempi bui ma io lo
ricordo con onore questo periodo ora
sono passati cinque anni quasi quasi
cinque anni dall'uscita di questo gioco
wow che bei tempi il 2014 che avete
signori sia un suv simulator che è un
capostipite videoludico di youtube
pensate come siamo messi per chi non
conoscesse got simulator tu sei una
capra e di fare cose allora io vi
ricordo niente 15 dalla vita che non ha
questo lo slow motion
ok io sono una capra che può fare cose
chi non ha mai visto questo video
cominciamo bene il crash del gioco
ragazzi è una feature del gioco hanno
fatto dei dlc dove gli scarichi
aumentano i crash fantastico
tu puoi leccare non è questo il tasto
per leccare aspetta che non mi ricordo
pida eccolo e questo a eccolo perfetto
ho trovato il tasto per leccare le robe
se tu letti le robe le cose ti rimangono
attaccate non si sa per quale strano
motivo
ciao età youth io però un posto
fantastico una volta allora ragazzi chi
si ricorda di questo ha avuto
un'adolescenza veramente [ __ ] a
un'infanzia dipende adico potevi entrare
vero portò in un posto strano
eccolo ti portava la merce del re capra
un giorno mi sono spaventato ma
ricordavo store che è successo a io sono
diventato il di il re capre per il trono
di capre r provocare i contadini cosa
che arrivano dal cielo eccoli grazie
allora vicini ai questa era la prima
mappa di gozzi violento sono
contentissimo mi ricordo più niente
ceramico è bellissimo perché non lo apro
veramente dal 2015 più o meno quindi
mamma mia cosa mi sono perso in questi
anni guardate che sfortuna altri ragazzi
non chiedetemi come possibile ma se
questa capra hanno sbagliato ho
sbagliato po il passo tornare indietro
ho sbagliato lo scivolo dicevo se questa
capra si schiacci la q lei muore e poi
ha poi far risuscitare con doveva iraq
dall cioè fantastico allora fratelli
sullo scivolo giusto let's go che bello
che avevo speso 20 euro per questo gioco
tutti ben spesi aggiunge
dalla madonna mamma guardami e poi
dicono che gta e violento ecco non
saprei definire se questo qua è un gioco
family friendly o meno perché non si può
parlare i maltrattamento di capre cioè
non penso è veramente figo amici miei
2019 è fatto un saluto testata big it
all altro e tradotto malissimo
questo lo devono vero pericolo
disponevano si cose ma che dove sono o
che è successo perché perché questa cosa
sta succedendo spiega mi sono finito
fuori dalla mappa perché ho fatto
saltare le cose di benzina va beh tutto
normalissimo questi sono fuochi
d'artificio si possono legare la finisco
continuamente fuori dalla mappa sto
gioco è fantastico anno soffitto fuori
oddio che segua riunisce i sacrifici e
non mi ricordo sta roba
penso da non fare devo portare roba per
fare i sacrifici lo quanto bello non mi
ricordavo niente a questa dovrebbe
essere lo studio di se mi alzo ve lo
dico tecnicamente questa casa
rappresenta lo studio dove hanno
sviluppato gop simulator perché questi
sono gli sviluppatori del gioco vedete
c'è proprio la mappa iniziale ed è un
gioco sviluppato benissimo un
intelligenza artificiale over tutto a
lui non gliene frega niente che il
computer vega sballottato signori
all'altro si 6 pienamente convinto nel
tuo lavoro amico salva i file ecco lui
non lo era come si fa a non amare questa
roba solo voi lo sapete ma che roba
perché lo proviamo a far vedere questo
gioco quelli di studio aperto con i tre
secondi buttano kakà sui videogiochi non
posso dire l'altra parola perché sono
youtube mi ammazza ecco perché noi vi
facciamo vedere got simulator
secondo me poi secondo me potrebbe
resettarsi il loro cervello direttamente
io non ho capito in tutto questo come
faccio a col mouse si gira e non avevo
capito è sempre un'emozione non me la
ricordavo quella no per cortesia la
vicino la pci mi serve
grazie non l'hanno beccata meno male c è
questo a questo successo signora
e serve una mano aspetti vabbè facciamo
alla prossima volta che dice il mio
obiettivo ragazzi che è una cosa che
riuscivo a fare ma adesso non so più se
ci riesco anche perché non mi ricordo la
procedura che in alto nel cielo c'è un
deltaplano che possiamo raggiungere le
care per attaccarci l'obiettivo di
questa mappa praticamente perché
l'obiettivo più difficile
so che non mi ricordo se qua a vedi qua
c'è una mano c'è la gru mi sa che devo
salire quest'opera giusto perfetto
saliamo in modo evidentemente tranquillo
e senza problemi questa scala una volta
salita dovremmo riuscire a farci a
quell'età plano mica invece la persona
sopra questo non va bene comunque devo
leccare il deltaplano non mi dicono come
si fa questa cosa e potrebbe essere
disturbante prof ci proviamo
c'è un tizio c'è un tizio qua fratello
scusami non posso fare nient'altro che
godermi il paesaggio con te hanno posto
dove faccio a buttarti giù invece posso
non buttarlo giù meno male
no io volevo ti giuro che non volevo
farlo mi stanno impegnando per non farlo
però no parco demonia parco o se
scoprendo anche di qua no per spettiamo
prossimo giro eccolo eccolo eccolo
pronti e difficile dove garantisco ci si
prova stesso ragazzi al primo tentativo
sono contento che le mie skill non sono
diminuite per passare del tempo questa è
una grande soddisfazione pre golia che
tutto il mio impegno in cui nel mio
lavoro in quello che faccio alla fine a
risultati questi sono i risultati che
nella vita ho sempre desiderato di
raggiungere ciao mamma
qual è a tuo figlio che lavoro fa è 6
con mamma non sei contenta nel 2014
forse non lo era ancora non mi ricordo
allo ragazzi prova a darmi un po di
propulsione per vedere se si può
arrivare da qualche parte anche se ormai
l'obiettivo del gioco per l'intero
aggiunto di questa mappa almeno è la
prova a prova lanciarmi tipo fionda
ragazzi a jachia male che male ci provo
raga fermi tutti a fratello è tutto
nelle tue mani per forza vai così ho
sbagliato tasto porca vacca cielo quasi
a vedere chi se ne frega andiamo a rado
visto che c'è un raduno di là
mi ricordo che era divertente solo
questo mi ricordo ciao fratelli guazza
bene non penice bit tu stai zitto facile
raduno ragazzi venite qua oggi mi
insegno bravo ragazzi non capisco
l'inglese in inglese era una capra però
va bene non fa niente andiamo avanti
signori cristiano è come baggio bene
chiaro aspetta prova la rovesciata di
cristiano fermi nota nessa ho fatto la
cross bar senza volerlo e questa era da
real madrid
incredibile alla vecchia e buona youtube
quanto ci manca tutti quanti ragazzi e
quelli erano veramente bei tempi anche
adesso in realtà è molto carino perché
oggi saranno i bei tempi di domani i
ragazzi godete dicono che c'è perché un
giorno non ci sarà più e come potete non
godervi questo come potete non come
potete lungo derby
ve lo dico io guardatevi video vecchi
negozi molto perché facevo e sentite
quanto ero inascoltabile come persone
generale e ceo di ciò ed a firenze ai
che il name and her dose mar
l'hc il in the name of the people kill
the cell phaidon need to kill the il
predatore uccide la sua
il predatore uccidere le prende si
uccidono finalmente un momento gioioso
nella mia vita
carino c'è un momento in cui si ferma
che testata che un momento in cui si
ferma sta roba no immagine
vabbè andiamo dico per messico
toglietevi mio turno
anzi può venire con me siccome ti
diverti viene ragazzi io sì che sono un
rimorchiatore guarda qua la madonna che
botta meno male che di gomma sta a fare
posso provare usare sta roba
le carote o buongiorno
qualcuno mi spiega come che cosa sta
succedendo qua perché umano mi sta
cavalcando chi t'ha dato il permesso
my darling sei tu eccolo l'elicottero
mazza quanto passa può solo veramente
riuscito a prenderlo ma non avrei mai
detto solo fortissimo ma c'è un party da
sopra per male che si divertono c'è del
mouse che fa il dj live adatto sia si è
fermato qual è il tipo c'è un elicottero
no io volevo farmi un giro non mi fermo
al party purtroppo vorrei e aspetta ecco
esattamente mancato tutto quello che
volevo prendere ragazzi spero che vi sia
piaciuto
questa è la con simone ha fatto un
replay di un gioco che penso sia nella
top 3 dei giochi più visti forse del mio
canale immagino non lo so nel caso vi
steste chiedendo il perché me lo sono
sempre chiesto anche io non ho mai
trovato una vera e propria risposta a
tutto questo però ok ragazzi spero che
vi sia piaciuto questo è stato il replay
più bello che ho fatto quasi ragazzi
semplicemente mi piace anche a rischio
l'equilibrio data iniziale se lo sapessi
iscrivetevi e noi ci vediamo come sempre
a un prossimo video da ragazzi
[Musica]